yuichi fer cuz apparently the devil no
longer wears prada and definitely
doesn't work for Vogue Gucci fur is a
hacker behind some of the biggest tax in
recent history targeting politicians and
celebrities alike but in January
Gucci fur was got and after years of
flying under the radar local media
finally snapped the first photos of
voter fraud officer dr. Najib u Chief
Edward ream vet who turned out to be 42
year old Romanian cab driver Marcel
Lazar lehel but he was such a nice man
blehh he'll confess to the hacking and
on June 7th was sentenced to four years
in a Romanian prison he began releasing
his hacked gems in 2013 to the website
The Smoking Gun and in emails to the
site called his victims the Illuminati
that the world of tomorrow will be free
of so just who are the so called
Illuminati Gucci fur took aim at drum
roll please the Bush's including former
US President George W who you might say
owes his painting career to Gucci furs
tricks in January of last year the
hacker leaked images of w's bathroom
self-portraits thankfully all save for
work
just not for lunch Gucci fur also
targeted Bill Clinton when he leaked the
former American presidents doodles on
official White House Doc's one of which
features a drumstick and an excited man
right next to the name of former Senator
Bob Dole let's leave that one to the
family therapist then there were the
seamy emails from Colin Powell to the
European Parliament member karrina kratu
and the changing of John Negroponte easy
mail password the former American
ambassador to Honduras in the early 80s
during a time when the Honduran military
committed human rights abuses against
its own people received the new password
haand baby kill one he also nabbed the
email accounts of celebrities like
Nicole Kidman and Lennar
Caprio the phone numbers of Robert
Redford and Warren Beatty and released
the first 50 pages of Candace Bushnell's
latest book someone's not as Sex in the
City fan how did he do it
guessing that's right Gucci forgets the
passwords to that counts he hacked based
on their personal info gleaned from the
web then he used the hacking technique
hopscotching whereby a hacker accesses
someone's email contacts to find their
next victim
but author Diane Nick Porter whose gmail
password fell prey to the hacker wrote
in a New York Times op-ed piece that
Google not Gucci fur bears the blame for
not doing more to protect her so for all
you Illuminati out there maybe it's time
to change your passwords and make sure
to include numbers letters symbols
animals and minerals